The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
On Monday, we went through and
looked at the functional forms
for sp two hybrid
orbitals, as found in the case
of the BH three molecule.
Now, you should recognize that
there are other hybridization
schemes that go along with
different geometries.
So, BH three was
trigonal planar.
And we are going to talk some
more about BH three today.
If you had been considering
last time instead a tetrahedral
carbon atom, then the
hybridization scheme we would
have needed to develop would
have been the sp three
hybridization scheme.
That would be associated with a
tetrahedral carbon atom.
On the other hand,
if we had a linearly
coordinated carbon atom or some
other main group atom,
boron or beryllium,
for example,
then we would have had to
develop the sp hybridization
scheme.
You should not miss the forest
for the trees in putting into
context from my previous lecture
on the sp two specific
case for that type of geometry.
But now, rather than going
through more examples of valance
bond theory treatments of
molecules, instead,
it is time for me to introduce
you to the tenants of the
molecular orbital theory for
treatment of molecular
electronic structure.
I mentioned valance bond theory
as having been introduced by
Linus Pauling.
And then, I also named Robert
S.
Mulliken, MIT undergraduate,
as the father of molecular
orbital theory.
And these are both two
different perspectives on
viewing electron structure of
molecules that arises from the
results of quantum mechanics.
In the case of valance bond
theory, we have a situation
where you have localized
electron pairs.
In the case of molecular
orbital theory,
electron pairs are still going
to be important,
but they are going to be able
to be delocalized over the
entire molecule in some cases.
So, this is very different.
This is a major difference
between MO theory and valance
bond theory.
In the case of the BH three
molecule that we
considered last time,
you had four positively charged
nuclei.
And you arrange those four plus
charges at the points in space
that correspond to the
equilibrium geometry of the
molecule.
And then you sprinkle in your
six valance electrons,
and you want to understand how
those six electrons become
organized in space in response
to that electric field set up by
those four positively charged
nuclei.
And we took the approach last
time that we are going to
localize electron pairs in
between nuclei.
And, because structurally the
BH three molecule is
symmetric and the three
hydrogens are indistinguishable
from one another,
we decided that we were going
to make hybrids.
And so we talk about
hybridization.
The idea behind hybridization
was to change the atomic
orbitals of boron by mixing
them, so that we would have one
that would be able to point at
each of the three hydrogens in
space to form three nicely,
perfectly directed electron
sigma bonds between boron and
hydrogen.
That was the scheme that we
adopted, this hybridization
scheme, but in MO theory we are
not going to do that.
We are not going to interfere
with the intrinsic atomic
orbital structure of a boron
atom in order to make bonds.
And we are going to see that
there are some predictions that
come out of the MO treatment for
the molecule that differ from
those that came out of the
valance bond treatment for the
molecule.
And so here,
no hybrids.
In terms of just the vernacular
of chemical structure,
you will hear sp three
as being used interchangeably
with the notion of a
tetrahedron.
But in valance bond theory,
it refers to a particular
hybridization scheme in which we
actually mix s and p as a
preparative to bond formation in
a molecule.
And we mix the atomic orbitals
on that central atom in a
hybridization scheme.
In MO theory,
we are not going to do that.
It is very important that you
keep these theories and the
language associated with the
theories separate in your minds
so you can see the difference
between these theories.
And then one of the
consequences of this valance
bond theory and the
hybridization scheme is that it
is not so good for excited
states.
And what that means is that we
were developing a scheme to
describe the bonding in the
molecule in its ground
electronic state.
Molecules can have excited
states, just like atoms can have
electronic states.
And over here,
in molecular orbital theory,
we are going to find that we do
a much better job with excited
states.
And that is important for
understanding the range of
properties associated with
molecular systems.
And you are going to see,
indeed, that the energy level
scheme for the six valance
electrons in the BH three
molecule is different,
depending on whether you use
valence bond theory or molecular
orbital theory.
Now, for molecular orbital
theory, we are going to need,
again, like we do for valance
bonds, to have some kind of a
procedure for forming molecular
orbitals, conceptually.
And the first step in such a
procedure is that you are going
to want to analyze the
three-dimensional shape of the
molecule.
And we do this,
of course, when we talk about
the valance-shell electron-pair
repulsion theory for predicting
molecular structure.
We are going to look at the
structure.
And we want to identify,
usually by inspection,
sets of symmetry-related --
-- atoms or orbitals.
And here, I am talking about
atomic orbitals.
I will come back in a moment
and talk about what I mean by
symmetry-related.
This is a concept that can be
put on a very nice,
firm, mathematical footing.
And, in fact,
if you find this type of
analysis interesting and would
like to see more of the math
that can help you to organize
the results of quantum mechanics
in terms of symmetry,
then you will want to put the
5.04 subject on your calendar
for the future.
That subject is devoted,
in large part,
to the applications of group
theory to chemistry and chemical
problems.
And symmetry plays a big role
in that.
And then, two,
we are going to form
combinations.
And let me just further
quantify this by saying we are
going to form linear
combinations --
-- of symmetry-related
orbitals.
One of the big approximations
that we usually kind of take for
granted in the molecular orbital
theory of electronic structure
is the LCAO approximation.
I am just going to mention that
parenthetically,
here.
This is that we can form
molecular orbitals that will be
linear combinations of atomic
orbitals.
This LCAO approximation arises
from the fact that we can solve
the Schrˆdinger equation exactly
for the hydrogen atom,
but for big molecules and many
electrons systems,
we cannot.
And what we like to do is to
take the atomic orbital wave
functions, that is,
atomic orbital here in LCAO,
and use those wave functions in
our approximation of molecular
orbitals.
We are saying that we can
combine these atomic orbitals on
the atoms that are in a molecule
to form the molecular orbitals
that will be able to spread out
and delocalize over the entire
molecule.
This is inherent in the
development of the theory that I
am working on here.
And you should see that this
will pop up in a number of
cases, but it is an inherent
approximation that we are
accepting.
And then, three,
we are going to combine the
linear combinations from part
two --
-- with central atom atomic
orbitals.
And that is what we will do.
And if we have done that
properly, we will have arrived
at molecular orbitals for the
system in question.
Now, I want to take a little
bit of time to go through each
one of these steps in order to
define the problem that we have
for this alternative way of
viewing the electronic structure
of the BH three molecule.
Now, why am I choosing the BH
three molecule for this?
Well, I am choosing it because
it is an easy problem and one
that is illustrative of the
steps that go into forming
molecular orbitals for a system.
In your textbook,
you will see that before you
get to something like BH three,
first diatomic
molecules are considered.
Those, I will show you on
Friday, are actually a little
trickier to understand than is
the case with BH three.
That is because in molecular
orbital theory we have the same
number of MOs as AOs.
If we start out with a certain
number of atomic orbitals that
come into play by virtue of the
atoms that are in the molecule,
then that number of orbitals
will be the same as the number
of molecular orbitals that we
will get at the end of the
problem.
They won't all be filled.
We will have some that are
empty.
But we are going to have the
same number of molecular
orbitals as atomic orbitals that
go into the problem.
And so what that means is that
the complexity of the problem is
related to the number of MOs
and, hence, the number of AOs.
The complexity of the problem
scales with the number of atomic
orbitals in the problem.
We actually call these our
basis functions.
And one of the things that John
Pople talks about,
if you have gone and looked at
his video that I pointed you to
in the problem set,
he talks about the wonderful
fact that our computational
power has gotten so great,
and will grow so much greater
in the future,
that we are able to
computationally handle problems
of the calculations of the
properties of enormous molecules
that bring into a problem an
enormous number,
a vast number of atomic
orbitals.
And so, a great computational
power is necessary to apply
molecular orbital theory,
or even the more recent density
functional theory,
to problems of electronic
structure that we need to
grapple with in order to predict
properties of molecular systems.
And in the BH three
molecule, which is,
as I said, a simple problem of
electronic structure and a nice
illustrative one for today's
purposes, we have,
this is a seven orbital
problem.
Why is this a seven orbital
problem?
It is a seven orbital problem
because boron has four valance
orbitals, an s,
a px, a py, a pz.
And we have three hydrogens,
each with their 1s orbital.
We have our valance orbitals on
boron.
We don't count the 1s orbital
on boron because that is filled
and is a core orbital,
and it doesn't get involved in
chemical bonding.
The valance shell for boron is
the n equals two shell.
We have 2s, 2px,
2py and 2pz.
And we have three hydrogens,
each with their 1s orbital.
If we were to tackle right now
the problem of the molecular
orbital energy level diagram for
a diatomic molecule like O two,
dioxygen,
we would find immediately that
this analysis of how many atomic
orbitals we have available would
give us the value eight.
And so it is a more complicated
problem.
It has one more atomic orbital
than this problem,
even though this one has four
atoms because three of these
atoms happen to be hydrogens,
which only bring in one orbital
to the problem.
That is why I am choosing this.
And then, in addition,
I am choosing this because the
consequences of the symmetry of
the BH three molecule
are that the orbital
interactions that we are going
to identify occur in nice
pair-wise sets.
And that makes things
especially easy to see in terms
of how chemical bonds arise in
the context of MO theory for a
problem like this.
And so, to now go ahead and
carry out step one for this,
we are going to draw the
molecule and try to identify
sets of symmetry-related
atoms/orbitals.
And, before you do that,
I just would like to show you
an example of a highly symmetric
molecule, because this notion of
symmetry is something that,
at this point in time,
I really only want you to gain
an intuitive grasp of,
I am not going to quantify it.
But, if you look at a molecule
like the one I have placed on
the left and right-hand screens,
you will see that it is a
large, round molecule.
Actually, round,
spherical things are the most
symmetric things that we can
think of.
Here, you can imagine that this
is a big ball with atoms located
at various points on the surface
of the ball.
This is just a ball and stick
representation of the C60
molecule, also known as
Buckminsterfullerene.
It is a geodesic dome-type of
molecule.
This molecule has the chemical
formula C60.
There are no hydrogens in this
molecule.
All the atoms are displayed.
And each carbon atom sits in a
position where it is adjacent to
one five-membered ring and two
six-membered rings on the
surface of this spherical
molecule.
And that is true of every
carbon atom on the surface of
this whole molecule.
As you go on in chemistry,
if you go into the analysis of
molecules using nuclear magnetic
resonance spectroscopy,
you will find that it is really
important to be able to identify
the symmetry of a molecule.
And you will realize that the
symmetry of the molecule is
manifest in the nuclear magnetic
resonance spectrum of a
molecule.
If you take the carbon-13
nuclear magnetic resonance
spectrum of this molecule,
a sample composed of this
molecule, you will see that
there is only a single C13
signal in the spectrum.
And that is because all 60
carbon atoms are in an identical
environment in this molecule.
Every one of them feels exactly
like everyone else.
They are all equidistant from
the center of this molecule.
And they are all equidistant
from their set of neighbors.
And so, in that way of looking
at a molecule,
you would see that they are all
equivalent.
You may have encountered this
molecule before,
but this molecule's discovery
--
-- was actually predicted
initially from analysis of mass
spectrometry data by Professor
Smalley, a Nobel Prize winner
whose efforts in this area have
spawned off chemistries
involving not only these
nano-sized balls of matter,
but also nanotubes made of
carbon, and this whole area that
we think of nano technology.
Really a lot of it is dominated
by the chemistry of new forms of
carbon that arose with the
discovery of
Buckminsterfullerene.
And that is just one example of
a new allotrope of carbon that
was discovered in recent years.
This gives you an idea for
symmetry.
I could show you pictures,
actually, of enormous
biomolecules.
There are large viruses that
are composed of biopolymers,
macromolecules that pack in a
way that is symmetrical,
so that you can see these
things.
If you view them in the right
kind of representation,
you will be able to see the
symmetry in them.
And one definition of symmetry
that I would like you to take
away from this picture is just
that each of the atoms that are
symmetry-related is
indistinguishable.
If you turn the molecule around
and look at the atoms,
those that are symmetry-related
are indistinguishable from one
another.
And so, when we have a trigonal
planer BH three
molecule, is the boron symmetry
related to any of the other
atoms?
No, it is not.
What about this hydrogen?
I labeled them last time A,
B, and C.
This hydrogen labeled C,
is it symmetry-related to other
hydrogens?
Yes.
And that is because of the
symmetry of this molecule with
these 120 degree bond angles on
the planarity of the molecule.
So, you have a set of three
hydrogens.
And their 1s orbitals are in
space indistinguishable from one
another.
They are related by symmetry.
And so, in this problem here,
we have four orbitals here on
the boron that are not
symmetry-related.
And then also incidentally let
me point out that the boron atom
is located at the center of
gravity of this system.
If atoms are going to be
symmetry-related,
they must not be located at the
center of gravity of the system.
Let's go over here and expand
on these ideas.
The method that I am going to
develop here for forming the
linear combinations has to do
with thinking ahead,
in this problem,
to the fact that we are going
to want to make linear
combinations that have the
correct symmetry to bond to
atomic orbitals on the central
boron atom.
Let me draw the ones that are
going to be relevant to this
part of the problem.
This one over here would be the
boron pz orbital,
so it has one positive lobe
coming out of the board,
negative lobe going back.
Over here we would have the
boron py orbital using the
coordinate system that I had
chosen last time,
which is x up and y to the
left.
And then here we have the
boron's px orbital.
And then over here we have the
boron's 2s orbital.
And so, our challenge now will
be to construct linear
combinations,
we are at part two,
of the set of three hydrogen 1s
orbitals that can match in
symmetry the boron central
atom's atomic orbitals.
Last time, remember,
for hybridization,
we were making these orbitals
mix with each other in order to
point at the hydrogens.
Now what we are doing is kind
of an inverse concept.
We are going to mix the
hydrogen orbitals so that they
have the right symmetry to
interact with the central atom
atomic orbitals.
There is a nice parallelism
here.
Here is going to be our LCs.
They key feature of the boron's
2s orbital is that it does not
have any nodes.
Remember nodes are surfaces.
When you pass from one side of
a node to the other,
you get a change in sign of the
wave function.
And we indicate that change in
sign by differential shading.
The 2s orbital has no nodes
whatsoever.
And a way that we can construct
a linear combination that has
the same spatial,
nodal properties as that boron
2s atomic orbital is as follows.
We can involve contributions
from each of the three hydrogen
1s orbitals.
Remember this one is A,
this one is B,
and this one is C.
This is going to be a linear
combination of the three
hydrogen 1s orbitals.
I will write this one as
follows.
This one will be written as A
plus B plus C.
That indicates the 1s orbital
on A, plus the 1s orbital on B,
plus the 1s orbital on C.
And, as we talked about last
time, wave functions that we
write should be normalized.
And they should satisfy the
unit orbital contribution rule.
For normalization,
here, I give a factor of one
over root three for this linear
combination formed as a symmetry
match with the boron 2s orbital.
You can see,
I hope, what we are doing.
We are projecting the nodal
properties of the central atom
atomic orbitals onto the linear
combinations that we are
forming.
And we are going to form a
complete set of three linear
combinations in this way.
Let's make one that has
symmetry properties that remind
us of this px orbital.
On HA we are going to have a
positive contribution to match
the positive contribution of
this lobe of the px orbital that
points along the plus x axis.
And then down here we are going
to have contributions from
hydrogens B and C.
And they are going to be
smaller, and they are going to
be opposite in-phase.
They are going to be opposite
in-phase because we are building
a linear combination that has a
node approximately at the center
of the system here,
so as you go from positive x
into the negative x region of
space, the wave function changes
sign to match the change in sign
associated with the px orbital.
We are projecting the nodal
properties of px onto the linear
combination of hydrogen orbitals
that we are forming here.
And this one,
written in normalized fashion,
will be root two over three,
A minus one-half B minus
one-half C.
And, although what we are
working with here are linear
combinations of these
symmetry-related hydrogen 1s
wave functions,
you are going to find that
these coefficients on the atomic
orbitals, that contribute
eventually to the molecular
orbitals, are going to come out
as normalized and as unit
orbital contributions.
So that if we started out this
problem with a single 1s orbital
on HA, that will be entirely
accounted for among these linear
combinations and the molecular
orbitals that we are going to
make with them.
Now, let's generate a linear
combination having the nodal
properties of py.
And, in order to do that,
we need to have a negative
coefficient out here in the
minus y direction.
We are going to put in a
contribution from HC as
negative, like that,
to match that.
And then over here,
we are going to make a
contribution for HB that is
positive.
And then, noting that there is
a nodal plane along the
y,z-plane, which comes out of
the board like this,
so that we are always negative
along minus y and we are
positive along plus y.
We match that here.
And the coincidence of that
nodal plane with the location of
HA dictates no contribution from
HA to this orbital,
for reasons that actually we
looked at last time,
--
-- namely, that we cannot bring
a hydrogen 1s orbital in here
and also change sign on going
half-way through that hydrogen
1s orbital, because s orbitals
have to have the same sign
everywhere.
It does not contribute to this
linear combination.
And our normalized form for
this will be one over root two B
minus C.
And then, if I were to ask the
question, can I make a linear
combination of the three
hydrogen 1s orbitals that has
the same nodal properties as pz,
the answer would be no because
they all lie in the x,y-plane
and they are just s orbitals and
cannot change sign as you go
through the x,y-plane from plus
z to minus z.
And so, we are done here.
And what you are going to find
is that we have created these
three linear combination
according to step two.
And taking into account both
the symmetry properties of the
molecule to identify a set of
three symmetry-related atoms and
orbitals.
And then, taking into account
an analysis of the nodal
properties of the central atom
atomic orbitals,
so that we could project those
out to help us find appropriate
linear combinations for mixing
with the central atom orbitals.
And, when we do that mixing,
we are going to find out that
there are three ways that we can
do it.
We are about to move onto step
three of this problem.
We are going to need to combine
these linear combinations with
the central atom atomic orbitals
according to the rules of MO
theory to generate,
first, bonding molecular
orbitals.
And the bonding molecular
orbitals that we will get will
be an in-phase combination --
-- of our LCs,
our linear combinations of
atomic orbitals,
with our boron atomic orbitals.
That will describe the chemical
bonding in our system.
And we will see that it
contrasts in a very interesting
way with the hybridization
scheme developed last time.
And the key phrase to
underline, here,
is in-phase.
And what that in-phase means is
that when two positive lobes of
two orbitals centered on two
different atoms are juxtaposed
and neighbor one another and can
have good overlap of their
atomic orbital wave functions,
that leads to in-phase
constructive interference and
stabilization of the electrons
associated with that newly
formed bonding molecular
orbital.
And that stabilization is what
we call the chemical bond.
The analogy to that in valence
bond theory is the idea that a
pair of electrons associated
with two nuclei in a sigma bond
is more stable because it
experiences, simultaneously,
two positive charges.
And here we are generalizing
that and allowing electrons to
flow over the molecule as a
whole.
But now we have a new concept,
and that is antibonding.
Antibonding molecular orbitals
will be out-of-phase
combinations that are repulsive
and lead to high energy
interactions.
And when, as in the case of the
problem we are considering here,
the interactions occur in
pair-wise sets,
we will find that we get very
nicely, for every bonding
molecular orbital,
a corresponding anti-bonding
molecular orbital.
Also, one of the interesting
things is that if you start
putting electrons into
anti-bonding orbitals,
if your system just happens to
be so constructed as to have
many electrons,
such that you fill up not only
the bonding molecular orbitals
of electrons to make the
chemical bonds,
but you continue on and you
have enough electrons to keep
going and put them into
anti-bonding orbitals,
those antibonds start to cancel
the bonds.
And so, you will see a very
nice progression of this as we
study the MO theory of the
homonuclear diatomic molecules,
starting on Friday.
And then, here is another
concept that arises from the MO
analysis of a molecule,
and that is that certain
orbitals can be non-bonding.
And an example of this would be
a lone pair of electrons.
And it happens when an orbital
or a linear combination of
orbitals finds no counterpart --
-- of like nodal symmetry.
These nodal properties of
orbitals are very important,
and I will show you later how
the nodal properties are related
to the energies of the orbitals,
as we consider them.
Having given you this preview
of how orbitals are going to be
able to combine in the MO
theory, let's see how it
actually takes place in the case
of BH three.
Now we are drawing another
example of an energy-level
diagram, where the energy is low
at the bottom and rises as it
goes up.
And these energy-level diagrams
that we are now developing for
molecules are analogous to those
that you studied earlier in the
semester for atoms.
And we are just generalizing
this notion to the atoms.
And what I am drawing over here
is our boron 2s orbital and here
is our boron 2px,
2py, 2pz orbital.
Those horizontal bars just
represent the energy of these
orbitals in the molecule.
Here I am just redrawing the
boron atom.
And then, over here on the
right, we are going to see that
we have our linear combinations
that we developed.
These are our three H 1s linear
combinations.
We found that the three
hydrogens in BH three
were symmetry equivalent,
so we generated linear
combinations.
The pictures of them are over
there.
I can give them names.
Why don't I call them D,
E, and F.
We have D constructed to match
the nodal properties of the
boron's 2s orbital.
E and F were respectively
constructed to match the nodal
properties of the boron's 2s,
2px, and 2py orbitals.
And I am showing you their
relative energies.
And now we need to do this
issue referenced here as point
three.
We need to combine these
things.
I have these on the one hand
and these on the other.
Our seven atomic orbitals have
been changed into four atomic
orbitals and three linear
combinations,
so I still have seven orbitals
total.
And now I am going to combine
these with these according to
their nodal properties to
generate seven molecular
orbitals.
And let's do it this way.
We are going to take linear
combination D that has been
constructed to match the boron
2s orbital in terms of nodal
symmetry properties,
and we are going to make a
bonding combination.
I am going to draw these
pictorially in a moment.
And, in this case,
those are the only two orbitals
in my seven orbital system here
that have that set of nodal
symmetry properties.
And for every bonding MO,
I must have an antibonding MO.
This is one of our molecular
orbitals.
And there is going to be a
corresponding molecular orbital
up here, high in energy.
And this will be an antibonding
molecular orbital that will be
the out-of-phase combination of
the boron 2s with this linear
combination that I labeled D.
Antibonding molecular orbitals
are usually denoted with a star.
We have a bonding combination
and an anti-bonding combination.
Now, we can form two more bonds
that will spread out over the
molecule because,
if you recall,
we had our px and py pair that
served as the nodal template for
our construction of linear
combinations E and F.
We are going to be able to
match up those to form two more
bonding molecular orbitals.
And these will be found to be
higher in energy than the first
one that we formed from D.
Here is a pair of bonding
molecular orbitals that derive
from linear combinations E and F
combining in-phase with boron's
px and py atomic orbitals.
And there will be a
corresponding antibonding
combination, where we allow
those orbitals to interact in an
out-of-phase manner.
And you will see what that
means shortly.
Let me put that up there and
add a star to indicate that this
high energy pair of molecular
orbitals is an antibonding pair
of orbitals.
I have six orbitals now in my
molecular orbital energy-level
diagram for BH three.
And that means I am not done
because I have to have seven,
and I started out with seven
atomic orbitals.
Look over here.
2pz was an atomic orbital on
boron that did not find any way
of serving as a template for
making a linear combination
involving the three hydrogens.
And so, it comes over here as
nonbonding.
It has no counterpart of like
nodal symmetry because of the
location of those three
hydrogens in the x,y-plane,
which is a nodal plane for the
boron pz orbital.
And so, this one is nonbonding.
These three orbitals up here
are anti-bonding.
And the ones down at the
bottom, which are the lowest in
energy, corresponding to being
able to most tightly hold onto
electrons in them are bonding
molecular orbitals.
And so our electrons can fill
into this MO energy-level
diagram in that way.
We have our six electrons that
come into this problem.
We have boron bringing in three
valance electrons and three
hydrogens each bringing in one
valance electron.
There are six electrons to put
into the diagram,
filling up three of the
molecular orbitals and then
leaving empty pz.
Let me introduce a little bit
more MO language right now.
This one here will be called
the highest occupied molecular
orbital, and this one here will
be called the lowest unoccupied
molecular orbital.
The reason why I am drawing
attention to these orbitals is
that in chemistry,
the chemical properties derive
oftentimes from those orbitals
that are in what is called the
frontier orbital region.
And the frontier orbitals are
those close in energy to the
HOMO-LUMO gap.
And I will come back to this.
But those highest energetically
lying electrons are going to be
the ones responsible for
nucleophilic properties of the
molecule and basic properties of
the molecule and reducing
properties of the molecule.
Whereas, low-lying empty
orbitals are going to be the
ones responsible for acidic
properties of the molecule or
oxidizing properties of the
molecule.
And we will come back to that
in a moment.
But that is something pretty
general and very useful that
comes out of studying molecular
orbital energy-level diagrams.
Now that we have the diagram,
let's see what the orbitals in
the diagram look like.
And I will try to do this
relatively quickly.
Here, let's start with the
lowest lying molecular orbital
in the system.
This is a representation of an
in-phase combination of the
boron 2s plus D,
where D is defined up here as
that linear combination.
This will be a molecular
orbital having the nodal
properties of a 2s orbital
centered on that central atom.
That is where our lowest-lying
two electrons reside.
Now, if you look at the LUMO
over there and then go up one
orbital in energy,
you will be looking at this
orbital, which is the boron 2s
orbital minus D.
And the thing that makes this
out-of-phase linear combination
so much higher in energy than
its in-phase counterpart is the
appearance, now,
of a nodal surface.
And this node is between the
nuclei.
It goes all the way around and
is between the central atom s
orbital and those peripheral
hydrogens.
And I will show you a picture
of it.
This is our BH three
LUMO plus one molecular orbital.
You can see that we have a wave
function in the center of one
sign.
And then, as we go along any
one of the B-H bond vectors from
boron to hydrogen,
we change phase midway along
the bond from positive to
negative.
And that is true,
no matter which of the three
B-H bonds we pick to traverse
along.
That one has the nodal
properties as drawn down there
for the boron 2s interacting in
an out-of-phase manner with
linear combination letter D.
And so, next time,
I will finish up and show you
what these other orbitals look
like as calculated.
I hope you have enjoyed this.
We will see more MO theory on
Friday.